great it's great to be with you all I'm
James Blair I work at posit as a product
manager for cloud Integrations So today
we're going to be talking about
different ways that posit workbench can
operate in different Cloud environments
through some of the Partnerships that
we're establishing
today now at posit we work really hard
to make sure that posit workbench meets
the needs of the modern data science
developer this includes giving you tools
and environments that allow you to do
the day-to-day workloads that are
important for your work exploratory data
analysis model training and tuning
deploying models managing things of that
nature exploring data visually with
tools like ggplot and other things like
that building shiny applications um you
know coding and working in other
environments like vs code and jupyter
notebooks are all things that are
supported under the posit workbench
platform now what's not often apparent
to developers as they're working in this
environment is is the underlying
infrastructure requirements that are
sometimes complicated in order to
support an enter an Enterprise product
like posit workbench to illustrate some
of this complication I want to take a
moment to look at some of the
documentation that we frequently share
with customers when they're setting up
posit workbench for the first time it
almost reads like a Choose Your Own
Adventure script you can install posit
workbench as its own environment it can
be a standalone server this is typically
the simplest approach often the approach
most people Breeze right past
you can also choose to use posit
workbench in a load balance environment
where I have multiple nodes configured
behind a load balancer and users are
assigned different nodes based on
different rules that might exist this
can be more robust but obviously adds
additional complication to the setup
process I could use posit workbench with
an external resource manager like
kubernetes now I have workbench set up I
have a separate kubernetes environment
set up workbench communicates with that
environment sessions launch in that
environment this is a supported
infrastru structure or I could run the
whole thing in kubernetes workbench runs
there the sessions run there everything
runs in kubernetes and then if I really
want to make things interesting I could
also run and integrate with slurm right
now some people look at this some
internal it organizations look at this
documentation and this is how they feel
they are salivating because they have
the knowhow they have the expertise they
have the infrastructure and it's almost
a plug-and-play exercise to get posit
workbench up and running and we applaud
those organizations
however I also recognize that lots of
people look at this and they feel more
like this right I'm overworked in many
cases I might be underpaid and I don't
have time to figure out what kubernetes
is let alone figure out how to use it
with this tool called posit workbench
that if I'm in the it organization I
probably have very limited familiarity
with what we've noticed is that a lot of
these administrators are starting to
turn to the cloud to find Solutions
they're looking for readymade services
or platforms that can alleviate some of
this administrative burden and Supply
users with the experience they want
without creating an undue maintenance
overload for the it uh professionals
within the
organization today we're going to talk
about a number of different solutions
that exist today and are coming in the
near future that allow posit workbench
and support posit workbench inside of
these different Cloud environments we'll
talk about some of the advantages how
they're how they differ from one another
and and provide some resources where you
can learn
more we'll start with with AWS or Amazon
web services we've partnered with Amazon
sagemaker so that it's possible for
administrators to configure a an Amazon
sagemaker domain to have access to our
studio in this process an administrator
goes in they either create a new domain
or they go to an existing domain that
exists in their sagemaker environment
and they make sure that there's a
there's a posit license in place and
they can configure access to posit
workbench and our studio within that
environment once that's been done
individual users can come into the
sagemaker platform and can request our
studio sessions from within that
platform when users make this request
they're brought to the familiar posit
workbench homepage but there's a few key
differences from what you might expect
out of a traditional installation one of
the biggest things here is that users
can request a specific compute instance
type for their session to run in this
means that every user gets an isolated
ec2 instance within AWS for their
particular session this accomplishes
this accomplishes two distinct things
one users can request resources based on
the workload they anticipate doing if I
have a huge data set and I plan on
bringing it into memory and analyzing it
I know I'm going to need a lot of memory
so I can make a choice when I start my
session to have an instance that
provides me with adequate memory for my
analysis on the other side maybe I have
an analysis that's going to require a
lot of parallelization across multiple
CPU cores to improve efficiency I can
request a Compu inance that has a high
CPU count so that my workload finishes
faster
the other advantage of this architecture
is that everybody's sessions run
independent of one another this is
hugely advantageous if you're like me
and you occasionally do something a
little bit silly in our studio and all
of a sudden the entire server is locked
up I'm sure I'm not the only one who's
tried to read a data set into memory
that far exceeded the available memory
in my
environment if that happens in a
traditional single server install I've
now brought the server down for everyone
I had to buy more than one round of
drinks to make up for that now
if you do the same thing here in the
sagemaker environment you need to reset
your session but other users are
unaffected right if I do something in my
session that causes me to exceed the
available resources I'll need to start
over and make sure that my new session
contains adequate resources but I am not
interrupting anyone else's workflow the
advantage here and this is true for all
of these solutions that we talk about is
that this comes without additional it
administrative burden the it office does
not need to worry about managing this
environment sagemaker handles the
orchestration of the resources and
everything behind the
scenes let's talk about Google Cloud
we've partnered with Google Cloud
workstations which is a fairly new
offering on gcp this offering is kind of
divided into two different personas
administrators Define workstation
configurations where they can Define
what resources are available for a given
configuration and what tools operate
there and then users can come into the
platform and request access to a given
workstation when a user makes this
request a dedicated environment is
created just for that user that provides
access to the tool set that was defined
in the configuration running on a
specific instance that was also defined
in that same
configuration when users come into the
platform they can see existing
workstations they have they can request
new workstations based on configurations
they've been given access to and then
they can launch workstations once
they're running and in the case of pait
workbench they will then have access to
all the tooling that they would expect
to have access to inside of a workbench
environment vs code the RC IDE Jupiter
notebooks Jupiter lab are all available
within this integration all it has to do
is configure these configurations to
Define what tools are available pait
workbench is available from a drop- down
list of tools you might want to make
available and then users can access it
in their own dedicated compute
environments next up is data breaks this
is one that we're very excited about
this is this is fairly new um we've
we've published a few blog posts in fact
one was published just last week that
highlights some of this um and there's a
number of things that are happening here
so I'll spend a little bit more time
here with data bricks one is we've made
a lot of progress recently on improving
the sparkly RR package to support some
new and exciting developments on the
datab break side specifically we're now
able to take advantage of datab breaks
connect from within sparklyr what that
means is I can remotely Connect into a
datab break session and environment from
anywhere I don't have to be collocated I
don't have to use use a datab brakes
notebook but I can have R Studio on my
desktop I can have posit workbench in
AWS I can have an R terminal in some
dusty server in a closet it doesn't
matter I can use sparkly R to connect to
datab bricks and facilitate workloads
that happen in the datab bricks
environment when I create these
connections the connections pan in the
upper right hand corner of the r Studio
IDE will show me details about the data
the cataloges the schemas everything
that's available to me from that databas
context I can explore that data I can
connect to it I can manipulate it and
all the computation happens on the data
bricks
end we're also excited because we're
creating a new feature inside the r
Studio IDE that's part of posit
workbench that will allow datab brick
users to manage their clusters directly
from the IDE this means that if I'm
using data breaks and I have a cluster
that I want to connect to but it's not
started yet I don't have to open a
browser log into Data breaks visit the
control plane click on start cluster
come back to the ID wait for the cluster
to start connect to the cluster and then
work I can start the cluster directly
from our studio once it started I can
connect directly to it and begin working
and this will be available in an
upcoming release of of posit
workbench the last thing that we're
excited about and this is more
forward-looking this is not something
that's available yet we anticipate being
available next year is posit workbench
as a Lakehouse application data brecks
back in June announced Lakehouse
applications as a way to run third-party
applications natively directly on datab
breaks infrastructure what this means is
that coming soon like I mentioned some
next year you'll be able to run posit
workbench directly on your Lakehouse INF
excuse me directly on your data breakes
infrastructure in a way that's supported
stable and provides users with the
experience they
expect I'll mention snowflake briefly
this is one that we are in the very
early stages with but we're working
closely with snowflake engineers and
developers to make it possible to run
posit workbench as part of snow park
container services which is a recently
fairly recently announced uh new
development over at snowflake the the
idea is that you'll be able to run pait
workbench directly within your data
excuse me directly within your snowflake
environment and when you do that you'll
also have access to the same connections
pane that we looked at previously that
will allow you to explore the data
that's available to you within snowflake
run queries against that data use that
data for analysis all while staying
within the realm of your snowflake
architecture and infrastructure this is
still really early phases so more
documentation and more examples will be
available soon as we continue to work
through this integration
finally last but not least we have posit
Cloud we've done a lot recently to make
posit Cloud more robust more capable and
more featur as we've listened to
feedback from our users this is a really
great kind of low barrier way to get
exposure to some of the products and
features that we offer to Enterprise
customers anyone can create an account
on posit cloud and from that account you
can create workspaces you can create
projects that are you leveraging either
the r Studio IDE or jupyter notebooks
and from those projects you can then
publish things things to posit cloud and
share and distribute those with others
and we continue to build out this
platform to improve the user
experience as we look towards the future
it's clear that the cloud landscape is
always shifting right there's new
technologies that arrive there's
technologies that disappear but here at
pait we remain committed to making sure
that regardless of where your
organization chooses to operate we are a
natural fit that our products work well
in those environments and that in many
cas we find ways to make sure that they
not only work well but they work in a
way that doesn't add additional burden
to it organizations that are often
already
overworked we look forward to a future
where all of posit team not just posit
workbench but posa connect posit package
manager are available in these different
Cloud environments and it's something
that we are diligently working towards
with all these different
Partnerships so what's next if you
attended today and didn't see your cloud
provider or or cloud service of choice
in what we've talked about feel free to
reach out to me you can find me at
jamesp it.co I'd love to chat or set up
a discussion about things that you're
doing within your organization or tools
that you're using that you'd like to see
work better with posit tools and posit
products alternatively if you are a user
of one of these Services you use
snowflake you use data bricks you're
you're operating in gcp or AWS whatever
the case is if you have questions or if
you have feedback on the existing
Integrations again happy to receive that
and happy to have you reach out
here's a collection of resources these
are links that will take you to um
different blog posts documentation
things that outline some of the work
that's happening right now places that
you can keep an eye on for the future
this is all available if you scan the QR
code here this will take you to a GitHub
repository that contains the slides
links to everything that I've just
shared um and things like that but I
appreciate your time today thank you
very much and and we'll take some
questions thank you James so I have some
questions here actually um how does pet
choose which provider or features to
prioritize and is there any possibility
of a technical road map yeah this is
such a good question it's like um it's
more of like an art than a science right
so what I mean by that is each of these
Partnerships that we have is is kind of
this you know there's two sides to it
right we obviously want to make sure
that our products are as as well
represented and as well positioned as
they can be in each of these different
environments but we're also balancing
that against the needs demands
expectations of the group or or company
that we're working with and so a lot of
it just comes down to the requirements
that they might have or the expectations
they might have and where we end up
meeting in the middle um an example of
this would be sagemaker right Sage maker
has sagemaker Studio which is a Jupiter
lab based interface for interacting with
their platform so when we came to them
and then when when we started these
discussions about posit workbench one of
the things that they didn't want to do
was they didn't want to enable Jupiter
notebooks and jupyter lab and vs code
within workbench because they wanted
python users to continue to rely on the
solution they provide and so if you use
Sage maker and and posit workbench today
you'll notice that the only editor
that's available in that context is the
r Studio editor because of some of the
trade-offs we made in our conversations
with with Amazon so my one of the things
that I focus on and and think about a
lot is how I can make sure that our
product Integrations are as consistent
as they can be across the different the
different uh partners that we partner
with but also while acknowledging that
in some cases there's expectations and
things that need to be taken into
consideration that might make the
experience a little bit different from
one to the other
so thank you um it's only providing our
studio or sag maker an AWS limitation
would you be able to run vs code in the
near future yes see previous response um
yeah so so I we've talked to them a lot
about that right um I you know I'd love
it if they opened up um some additional
functionality on the sage maker side in
all honesty I don't expect that that
that will change anytime in the near
future um but if you the one thing that
I'll say and this is true of of all of
you know any of these types of questions
is that if you have questions like this
around how come this isn't this way or
why is it this way let us know about it
but also if you have a relationship with
sagemaker if you're a sagemaker customer
an Amazon customer or with data breaks
or whatever Reach Out to your reps on
their end as well and provide that
feedback for them cuz cuz they're
managing their own road maps and we're
trying to kind of jointly work on that
with them but but these providers
getting that feedback directly is often
the thing that will help move things
forward the
best thank you so um I work in a highly
regulated industry do any of these cloud
service uh providers or provide
encryption in transit addressed and even
during use yeah that's a that's a really
good question um I know sagemaker has
several different compliance
requirements that it meets I know it's
stock to compliant there's hippoc
compliance there some other things that
are that are there on the sagemaker side
it really depends and that's a that's a
good question for the like the provider
the or the partner um one of the things
that I I don't have a clear answer for
right now is is you know as we look
towards the future with data bricks and
the work that we're doing there being
able to operate directly on datab bricks
infrastructure which means that data
wouldn't ever travel outside of your
datab bricks environment right workbench
would be there as you analyze data it
would stay within the realm of data
braks there might be some some things
there that meet some regulatory
requirements but that's that would be a
question better suited for data breaks
in that case thanks um so the next
question reads
um Can these Solutions connect to
package manager and have the workbench
environments use only packages available
based on freeze
dates what was the last part available
on on on freeze dates like froze free oh
free free gotcha yeah um
so yes is the short answer right it
depends on which particular integration
or partnership we're talking about for
example sagemaker lets you configure at
the like domain level when you set up a
sagemaker domain and configure our
studio you can supply a default uh
package repository URL and so if you
have like a snapshot from package
manager that you want every user to use
you can supply it there and then every
user session will by default point to
that location and other Solutions like
the gcp solution or the stuff that we're
doing with with Snowflake and things
like that um everything is is a little
bit further down the line where you're
managing containers and and uh image
definitions to provide users with access
to the tooling and so things could be
implemented at that level to set
defaults for Upstream repositories or
things like that thank you again
appreciate it James thank
[Applause]
you